à
m
généreuse elle est très généreuse
charitable
bonjour
je vais bien et vous
vous êtes au ruisseau à la rivière
saint-louis chez madame rocher s'éboule
oui c'est moi je m'occupe de mon jardin
j'ai un peu les petits enfants aussi de
temps en temps mais même si ma fille est
là et surtout je donne de mon temps
alors y'a pas en tant que bénévole pour
la broderie le patchwork pour les récits
longtemps aussi je vous en mets n'ont
pas de ce côté alors je plante un peu de
tout dans mon jardin c'est peut-être un
petit fou oui mais il ya des papayers
il ya du manioc
il ya des bananiers venait pour qu'ils
arrivent premiers fougueuse ces deux
gendres à huy et on passe par le chant
d'un d'abord c'est un peu la maison du
bonheur parce que j'aime bien j'aime
bien planté j'aime bien
regarder les fleurs le matin
et donc c'est ça ma fille
football je vis avec elle
depuis que j'ai été malade avec le
chikungunya le principal en fait c'est
trouver l'équilibré nono aux anciens
grands parents il faisait comment tout
le monde vivait ensemble la plupart du
temps prenez
ça surprend peut-être par un manque de
tolérance parce que c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas évident de vivre avec
quelqu'un et même en couple on a des
difficultés donc après sa mère et il
faut voir quand même que celle qui a
pris soin de nous moi j'ai été sensible
à ça le fait qu'elle qu'elle met tout
donner en fête venez on monte un
oui
ah oui vous savez c'est ce qui m'a sauvé
la voie
parce que je suis l'aîné de sept enfants
et vous savez de mon temps les parents
n'étaient pas gentil et j'ai été rejetée
par mon père et ma mère à la naissance
donc
j'ai trouvé quelqu'un qui pouvait
m'aider et elle m'a fait comprendre
vous avez eu mari est dieu dans ma vie
donc deux pays bas
oui et il accompagnait des enfants
alors chez un cadre ici où il ya mes
petits
g8
entendent et beaucoup de mamie dire moi
j'ai dit à ma fille si elle a envie de
me vois qu'elle vienne dans la semaine
mais le dimanche je suis toujours parti
je leur ai dit mais vous ne ressemblez
pas à ma grand mère
pourquoi je dis parce que les grands
mères s'aiment bien recevoir les petits
enfants passaient la journée du dimanche
avec les enfants et les petits-enfants
des mamies ont répondu ça c'est la mode
d'avant maintenant c'est plus la mode
nous on va danser moi je trouve ya un
temps pour promener un temps pour
chouchouter ses enfants
et c'est tout
tiens y'a quelqu'un
entrer bonjour j'ai du bon choix
jeannette
bonjour bonsoir oui alors c'est qui ces
jours c'est jean louis jean louis oui
c'est justice et jean c'est jean-louis
échanges risquent de loria pas un voilà
c'est l'aura pas ces lauréats parcours
loriot paul joseph fofé coûts ont baissé
c'est l'organisme qui s'occupe
des personnes âgées
de quoi séduire me répond
si ça devient des camarades ça devient
même des amis parce qu'on s'est un peu
comme une famille lauréats pas
ouais j'en étais responsable
c'est elle qui s'occupe de tous les
dossiers paul et pour les personnes
âgées s'il ya une personne qui n'est pas
bien qu'elle a su quelqu'un besoin des
dons qu'elle le prend en charge la
personne et s'occupe des papiers pour la
personne qui n'est pas capable de
s'occuper elle même on va manger parce
qu'après il faut le taxi vient me
chercher tu sais qu'il faut que je monte
à l'école trois morts
on est à l'école des trois mâts la
journée se poursuit
alors ce qu'il est le brevet vous alors
c'est madame pêcheurs et céline
simone joséphine
trois bénévoles va on va faire de la
future avec les enfants à l'école
bonjour
bienvenue au jour
oui
l'institutrice voulait faire des petites
hanche sont des petites manic parce
qu'on pourra pas faire autre chose le
temps est trop court et comme vous voyez
on a même des garçons qui courent bien
dans les écoles je le redis je leur
explique comment je vivais comment
j'allais à l'école ce qu'on mangeait
tout ce qu'on faisait avant d'aller à
l'école parce qu'avant d'aller à l'école
y avait des corps veillent comme
disaient les grands les grands les
parents fallait chercher de l'eau à la
fontaine il fallait balayer la cour
après on se préparait pour y aller à
l'école
alors des souverains ils disent c'est
pas possible
vos de notre passeport culturel et bien
grasse alors y'a pas que j'ai pu
connaître à travers ça justement eh bien
on a pu voir des personnes très dévoué
qui ont du savoir à transmettre
la france
très bien m'amuser
la
retarder
et après vous allez refaire ça vous
arrive vous coupez
n'est pas le à faire comprendre que ce
6e ils sont comme ça aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être par rapport à ce que les
anciens ont vécu
c'est le développement pour eux mais est
ce qu'ils sont vraiment heureux avec
tout ce qu'ils ont je ne pense pas jamie
même à un seul mais n'a beaucoup de
bénévoles qui ressemble pour un commun
déjà dans la tristesse dans le malheur y
en a toujours un sourire jane lynch a
una diabète par exemple n'est pas marqué
sur son front malade et là des bénévoles
au sein de l'orgue à pas qui font
dialyse trois fois par semaine qui sont
là qui sont cancéreux rien à dire donc
nous c'est une leçon d'humilité et c'est
comment dire ça c'est la joie de donner
aux autres et puis de ne pas se plaindre
c'est bon c'est la cloche
oui
c'est une manière pour elle en fait de
continuer à avoir des activités c'est à
dire même si elle est à la retraite
ça lui permet de sortir de voir du monde
d'apprendre aussi son savoir faire parce
que c'est un savoir faire quand même qui
se perd c'est à dire ça c'est dans le
cadre de l'échangé de compétences
transmission de savoirs savoir-faire au
niveau de l'arrière pas donc media luna
une richesse pas possible et imagina le
bénévole il monte rosa mais après il ya
des choses que ce site est chez elle ça
permet de devant moi ces quatre
nouvelles dispositions le dit jeannette
salé joly qui l'a fait mais dit voilà ce
numéro de jeanine et appelle jeanine
j'espère moi vous aurez l'occasion de
dans quelques années de continuer à
faire ce genre de reportages et de
trouver toujours une mamie qui aime bien
les enfants
qui s'occupe de ses petits-enfants et
qui partagent ce qu'elle sait faire donc
il faut qu'elle continue le plus
longtemps possible
tant que ce sera possible à cultive sait
bien que les élus prennent conscience
quad que peut il faut ces gens comme
jeanine les bénévoles tout seul dans le
cas de rejet nationale si on veut que
les enfants apprennent à aimer et à
donner il faut que les parents
d'aujourd'hui
sage aimait et donner parce que les
enfants vont grandir avec ce que vous
vous allez partager
bien urgence